like we're stuck at home late
red-flag I know for three days I should
go get firewood and we should go get a
couple days worth of something to eat
here caribou or few ducks the hailstone
family spends their summer living in
Kowalik away from their home in their
native village of Norvik this nomadic
lifestyle allows them to live off the
land and stockpile resources for the
harsh winter ahead we got to start
cutting down the tents and the teepees
and the kitchen we got to make sure
everything is put up we got 40 mile an
hour winds coming in for the next three
days the next three days we're gonna
need heat we're gonna need some fresh
meat and we're gonna need to just
basically secure our stuff
these are tents they can just blow away
and they can end up in the river they
can end up in the Willows it can end up
destroyed we got to get busy that's
really what we got to do you guys listen
weather report we have a 40 mile an hour
wind warning with gusts so we're gonna
just hunker down for a couple days
it ain't gonna be any good to go out in
the ocean and it gonna be any good to
have fires probably gonna be any good to
fish right now cuz gonna be such a low
tide with the north wind me and John are
gonna take off we're gonna go look for
the ducks geese whatever's in the river
few more logs yep a few more logs and
you ladies can just tidy up camp
anything that's loose and stuff has to
be picked up anything that's up on the
rack up there it's gonna have to be
nailed down or secured all right well
I'm gonna go get ready for boat I gotta
go get wood Hey look at me they're gonna
secure the camp around here and make
sure that everything's picked up and put
away and nothing is gonna blow away
because we can't just go the store and
replace things and it's just on us
Carol come in with these big rocks okay
take the whole teepee down and prepare
for the real I wouldn't that are coming
how fast is what I'm gonna be it's gonna
be like 35 to 45 miles per hour gusts
the cold is coming almost like best
winter so I'm gonna use these right here
to hold your girls distant down if it
starts to get funny or entire girls too
hard won't come just come off it should
hold you have to always just be prepared
because once your self to start blowing
it's pretty hard to keep all your stuff
dry clean and together so we're just
trying to make sure we have food
security or shelters secured and we have
enough heat there
I'm gonna take the chainsaw for wood
looks like you're ready for decent ducks
we'll see what we can come home with I'm
sure we can fill the boat so looks like
the winds already picking up this is
kind of nasty we've got my son John to
go boating with me today we've got
firewood to collect and we've got some
meat to secure we know the weather's
coming we know what to do to prepare for
it and we get with it
what'll kill you isn't the weather it's
not being prepared for it
and if you don't prepare yourself and
you don't go get the things that you
need before it happens you're gonna have
to do it while it's happening and that's
when you can get nailed